Você toma livro tiroxina religiosamente
todo dia em jejum, espera 30 minutos
para comer, faz os exames a cada 3
meses, o TSH volta normal e mesmo assim
continua exausta, cabelo caindo, pele
ressecada, raciocínio lento, ganhando
peso sem explicação. Seu médico ou
médica olha os exames e diz que está
tudo bem, mas você sabe que não está.
Uma revisão publicada na Curios em 2025
pela pesquisadora Ângela Matsa revelou
algo que a maioria dos endocrinologistas
ignora. Até 15% dos pacientes tratados
com levotiroxina mantém níveis de T3
abaixo do normal, mesmo com TSH
controlado. O problema não está na sua
tiroide, está na conversão. E é isso que
eu vou te explicar agora. Deixe contar
como funciona esse sistema. A tiide
produz principalmente T4, que é um
hormônio relativamente nativo. Pensa no
T4 como uma forma de armazenamento. Para
que esse hormônio realmente funcione nas
suas células, gerando energia, regulando
metabolismo, mantendo o seu cérebro
funcionando, ele precisa ser convertido
em T3. É a forma ativa. Essa conversão
acontece principalmente no fígado, mas
também nos rins, músculos e outros
tecidos. E quem faz esse trabalho são
enzimas chamadas deiodinases,
especificamente a deodinase um e a dois.
Aqui está o problema. Essas enzimas
dependem de nutrientes específicos para
funcionar e são sensíveis a uma série de
fatores que a medicina ortodoxa
simplesmente não investiga. O selênio é
o primeiro da lista. As deodinases são
selenoproteínas,
ou seja, tem selênio na composição, na
estrutura. Um estudo publicado no
Clinical Pediatric Endocrinology mostrou
que pacientes com deficiência de selênio
apresentavam T4 elevado, T3 baixo e uma
razão T4 T3 significativamente
aumentada. Quando o selênio foi
suplementado, o TSH caiu, o T4
normalizou e o T3 subiu. A conversão
melhorou, mas quem dena em paciente com
hipotiroidismo? Fora a galera da
integrativa, quase ninguém. O zinco
também participa da síntese e
metabolismo dos homônios tirodianos. Um
estudo publicado no International
Journal of Advanced Research encontrou
níveis significativamente reduzidos de
zinco em pacientes com hipotiroidismo
subclínico. O ferro é outro elemento
crítico. A deficiência de ferro
prejudica a função tirodiana e a
conversão hormonal. E o iodo, claro, é a
matéria-pra básica. Agora vem a parte
que complica ainda mais. O fígado é o
principal órgão de conversão de T4 em
T3. E adivinha o que que prejudica a
função hepática? Resistência insulínica,
esteatose, ou seja, gordura no fígado,
inflamação crônica? Uma revisão
publicada na Hepatology em 2025 detalhou
essa conexão. O fígado expressa
principalmente a deiodinase tipo um e
condições como o fígado gorduroso
alteram dramaticamente essa atividade
enzimática. Em estados de resistência
ulínica e inflamação, os níveis de T3
nos tecidos podem cair até 70 80%, mesmo
quando o T3 sérico ainda aparece normal
nos exames. Isso explica porque que você
pode ter TSH e T4 normais e ainda assim
sentir todos os sintomas de
hipotiroidismo. O hormônio não está
chegando onde ele deve ou precisa
chegar. E tem mais um fator que poucos
conhecem, que é a genética. Existe um
polimorfismo no gene da deudiodioginase
tipo 2 chamado THR92
ala, que pode prejudicar a eficiência
dessa enzima. Pessoas com essa variante
genética convertem em T4, em T3 de forma
menos eficiente, especialmente no
cérebro e na hipófise. O ensaio clínico
está recrutando pacientes agora, que é o
NCT 056824
está investigando exatamente isso. Se
passes com fadiga persistente, apesar do
tratamento com livro de ooxina, se
beneficiariam da adição de T3 sintético,
especialmente aqueles que carregam
variantes nos genes DIO2,
deodinase 2 e o MCT10.
Então, o que a medicina ortodoxa faz
quando você chega reclamando sintomas?
aumenta a dose de livro tiroxina, tem sh
ainda normal, então o problema não é
tiroide, deve ser a sua cabeça, deve ser
depressão, vai tomar um antidepressivo,
não enche o saco. Ou ansiedade ou
menopausa, mas ninguém investiga se o T4
está sendo convertido adequadamente.
Ninguém dóce T3 livre, ninguém avalia
selênio zinco e ferro, ninguém pergunta
sobre saúde hepática, resistência,
inflamação sistêmica. Um relato de caso
publicado na Curius em 2022 escreveu uma
paciente de 80 anos que desenvolveu
insuficiência cardíaca tomando
levotiroxina. O TSH estava elevado, o T4
livre estava alto, mas o T3 estava
baixo, ela não conseguia converter, só
melhorou quando adicionar o T3 ao
tratamento. A combinação salvou a função
cardíaca dela. Então o que que você pode
fazer com essa informação? Primeiro,
peça exames completos, não só TSH e T4
livre, mas também T3 livre e T3 reverso.
O T3O é uma forma inativa que compete
com o T3 ativo. Quando está elevado,
indica problema de conversão. Segundo,
investigue seus níveis de selênio, zinco
e ferro. Deficiência nesses minerais são
extremamente comuns e raramente são
investigados adequadamente. Terceiro,
avalie sua saúde do fígado, saúde
hepática. Você tem esteatose, tem
resistência insulínica, tem
sírometabólica. Esses fatores prejudicam
diretamente a conversão de T4 e T3.
Quarto, considere fatores de estilo de
vida. Estresse crônico eleva o cortisol
que inibe a conversão. Dietas muito
restritivas reduzem a atividade das
deodinases. Inflamação sistêmica, seja
de origem intestinal autoimune ou
metabólica, prejudica todo o eixo
tirodiano.
A verdade incômoda é que o tratamento
padrão do hipotiroidismo assume que todo
mundo converte T4 em T3 da mesma forma e
não converte. A genética varia, o estado
nutricional varia, a saúde hepática
varia, a inflamação varia. Para estar
todo mundo com a mesma pílula de
levotiroxina, esperar o mesmo resultado,
é ignorar a bioquímica individual. Se
você está tomando o seu remédio
direitinho, seus exames estão normais e
você continua se sentindo mal, o
problema pode não estar na sua tireoide,
pode estar na conversão e isso muda
completamente a abordagem. Não aceite o
rótulo de que é psicológico quando
existe uma explicação biológica que pode
ser investigada. Questione, peça os
exames certos, investiga os cofatores.
Seu corpo está tentando te contar algo e
agora você sabe onde procurar. Agora
saia do vídeo se você gosta superficial.
Eu preciso simplificar aqui por causa do
YouTube e das limitações regulamentares.
Na comunidade fechada não tem esse
filtro. Lá eu compartilho protocolos
completos, combinações precisas.
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames e casos clínicos que
não posso mostrar aqui é acesso direto
ao meu cérebro médico. Você tem lives
semanais, PDFs exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp, integração com quem está
realmente comprometido. Se você quiser
ir além, tem o nível dois, com ações
científicas de 2 horas a cada 15 dias,
dseando artigo por artigo e entrando os
bastidores que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. Seu nome aparece nos
vídeos, você se torna parte visível
dessa comunidade de elite. Poucos têm
essa coragem. A pergunta é: você está
entre eles?